just a few months ago the prospect of
these Thai youngsters soaking up the
atmosphere at the theater of dreams
would have been just that but today for
the wild boars their dreams became a
reality when the boys were rescued after
being trapped in a flooded cave
Manchester United told them they would
be welcome to visit and they were true
to their word
josie marino met the team at the club's
training ground yesterday and they got a
behind-the-scenes trip to Old Trafford -
today they were back again to watch the
Premier League encounter against Everton
in July the boys spent over two weeks in
the flooded cave complex near chiang rai
with no sunlight limited oxygen and
rationed food and water it took three
days to get them out with some of the
boys suffering lung infections after
their ordeal one of the divers who made
repeated trips into the cave to rescue
the team today is a proud moment we
never thought that we could get them all
out even when we first started that
first day as rescue there was always a
chance you know there was going to be a
some sort of incident and they could get
fatality but yeah I was impressed when
we finished then we actually gone
although if we get to the meeting the
mom sure it'd be quite emotional maybe
maybe maybe some tears coming out then
but I don't know this has been an
incredible few weeks for the wild boars
a remarkable story of first survival and
now almost celebrity status all of it
faced together as a team Fraser Maud Sky
News Manchester